there is no minimalist rulebook well
until now the minimalists have created
16 rules for living with less a free
ebook which you can download right now
and the minimalists com /resources enjoy
can you apply minimalism to politics we
kind of talked about that a little bit
we did I just wanted to talk about sort
of minimalist presidency what what would
that look like I don't know whether or
not you're a fan of Calvin Coolidge but
I do I'm a big fan of his values whether
or not he executed well on them I
actually think he probably didn't in his
second term because one of his kids died
anyway we have this essay on our website
someone asked us about being this the
minimalist president I just want to read
a few quotes from Calvin Coolidge so if
will your question is about could there
be a minimalist president well I think
the answer is yeah probably but I think
well I mean we don't need to do this
right now but I think that question
needs to define what minimalist
president is because when we ask that
question on the shorter podcast you were
like oh that means less government or
when I hear that question I think Oh
more intentional spending with the
government where someone else might
think communism which we have been
compared to communists in different
articles before so Calvin Coolidge was
the 30th president in the United States
during the the roaring 20s he followed a
very corrupt president Harding who is I
think a distant cousin of podcast Sean
actually warren g harding should we hold
that against shawn hardin all right
during the 67 months of Calvin
Coolidge's presidency the national debt
the federal government the federal
budget unemployment and consumer prices
shrank and the GDP expanded
significantly which led Coolidge his
biographer to call silent Hal a rare
kind of hero a minimalist president and
economic General of budgeting and so I
said but perhaps the best way to
understand Coolidge is minimalist ways
is through his own words so here's his
quote on contribution no person was ever
honored for what he received honor has
been the reward for what he gave and so
I mean that's a contribution is is
something that you're Ryan and I often
talk about when we talk about giving it
it's so much more if I gave Ryan
something and he it's
hey Ryan let's celebrate what you what
you received it doesn't work that way
it's about how are we able to contribute
beyond ourselves in a meaningful way on
spending he said there is no dignity
quite so impressive and no independence
quite so important as living within your
means I can't even imagine most
politicians even saying that now it
almost takes Kooks to say live within
your means yeah it's a capitalist right
or your your or your you know your
anarchist or whatever but why is I don't
know Kim why is living within the
government because they have the bill to
print money they don't even have means
right they don't produce seems like they
do put that on some people you know
they'll say whoa you want some handouts
all you need to live within your means
you know we're not gonna give you
anything where we got to go give these
other people a bunch of trillions of
dollars right yeah but you know to go
back to a minimalist government when
what came to mind for me was the Labour
Party in England so they just in the UK
they just had their elections and you
know Boris Johnson and the Tories ended
up winning but one of the criticisms
that people had against the Labour Party
was that when you looked at their
booklet of what they were proposing it
was like pages upon pages upon pages of
policies I mean they just needed to
whittle it down to just a few main
policies that you care about
right simplify it and I think what's
happened in both the Democrat and the
Republican parties and one thing that
the problem that we're seeing is that
people feel like they have to agree with
everything on the platform right in
order to be this XYZ so it's sort of the
purity test right where you have to
agree 100 percent and the problem is is
that they've expanded each of these
parties have expanded beyond just fiscal
policy or governmental policy they
include all these moral policies and all
of you know all of these various
different policies that are now
encompassed in and it's like you know
it's very difficult to have a nuanced
perspective even if you do agree with
somebody you know for me I say I I can
support a candidate if I agree with them
eighty-five percent is what I like yeah
ideally if they've
don't agree with Somebody Anybody 85%
than I have to obviously keep going down
the percentage right sure but 80 at some
point you've identified I'm not gonna
vote for either right right because I
just don't agree with either of them
enough to where yeah that why we need
more than two parties though this is
really why because otherwise too big
you're not gonna agree with 85% of just
about anyone if you have if it's Coke
versus Pepsi or right now you swamp
water versus toilet water or whatever it
is it's like would I rather drink I
don't know I just wait and when you have
platforms that are so large and you feel
obligated to agree with you know it's
easier for me to agree with 85 percent
of somebody's platform if their platform
has let's say five items right but if
their platform has 50 items we have to
go through all those 50 and figure out
what percentage of these do I agree with
right so if we just focused our politics
on things that were actually really
meaningful that government can actually
control then though and things that we
want government to control then we could
you know that is where I think we would
have like trying to dwindle down and I
think that's what we really need to do
we really need to dwindle down all of
these huge platforms that they just
include way too much yeah and then you
end up like the Labour Party in the UK
or it was like page upon pay I mean just
ridiculous policy after ridiculous and
policy and that's why it's so difficult
I know Ryan we were voting in the last
election on all the local issues and we
talked about local being so important I
had to spend my wife and I spent like an
entire day going through what's this
judge and this judge and in the in
finding information on people is
difficult right like some of the
candidates it's like you like it was a
note to self like if I ever which I
never would but if I ran for public
office you could go to what Orion
Nicodemus is political values calm we're
like some people like they they're
buried it's even hard to figure out what
their what their viewpoints are what
their positions are